pub
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est à munich que se déroule cette
année le 37ème congrès eucharistique
mondiale le cardinal van d'helle
inaugure les cérémonies qui vont se
dérouler sans interruption une semaine
durant devant une assistance de fidèles
de plus en plus grande au fil des jours
le cardinal testa vaud présente sa
sainteté jean xxiii auprès des autorités
ecclésiastiques du monde entier et de la
foule des congressistes qui sera bientôt
évalué à près d'un million de personnes
l'un des plus importants rassemblements
de masse enregistré en europe depuis
longtemps
dramatique accident à vienne en autriche
victime d'une défaillance de freinage un
tramway fou dévalé une colline et vient
s'écraser contre une rame venant en sens
inverse
14 morts et 30 blessés graves la
fatalité ayant voulu que le drame se
produise au coeur d'un quartier
résidentiel en fin d'après midi à
l'heure du plus fort trafic
dans toute l'europe l'été continue à se
singulariser en date un tous les records
en acquiert de plus 25% de
précipitations au dessus de la normale
en juillet et où prend la relève créant
partout des situations anormales voire
même dramatique la pologne connaît ainsi
ses plus graves inondations des trois
dernières d'écart la plupart de ces
fleuves en crue la vistule notamment se
répandent sur des centaines de milliers
d'hectares dont les récoltes sont
anéantis et dont les habitants
connaissent des heures tragiques
[Musique]
avec les transports interrompus le
sauvetage de plus de 30000 personnes du
sud du pays s'avère particulièrement
difficile et le bilan des morts et des
disparus s'élève de jour en jour la
tempête s'est vite aussi à l'autre bout
du monde sur valdivia cette ville du
chili qui fut aux trois quarts anéanti
par le tremblement de terre du 1er mai
et qui vit depuis lors sous la menace
des eaux du lac rhénus dont le déversoir
a été comblé par le séisme une nouvelle
secousse vient miraculeusement d'ouvrir
à déboucher au zoo prisonnière mais de
toute façon l'espoir n'existe plus à
valdivia dans le sol se trouve
aujourd'hui en dessous du niveau de la
mer les grandes marées du pacifique faut
prévoir le pire à brève échéance
et pour ceux qui n'ont pas voulu évacuer
leur ville quelques milliers d'hommes
sur les 80000 qui habitait là avant le
tremblement de terre
la seule issue est une bande de terre
resté à quelques mètres au-dessus des
eaux et sur laquelle se construit une
ville préfabriqués aujourd'hui encore
sans eau potable ni électricité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
expérience capital dans le domaine des
communications terrestres et spatiales
et savants américains viennent de
réussir en utilisant la lune comme
réflecteurs une liaison radio entre deux
points de la terre et me du new jersey
vers la lune
le signal réfléchie par celle ci est
captée en californie une telle
performance avait déjà été réussi avec
des signaux de radars très puissant mais
pour la première fois s'établit
aujourd'hui une conversation
téléphonique après un parcours de sept
cent soixante mille kilomètres et elle
est parfaitement claire et intelligible
lancé dans l'espace la réponse mais
quelques secondes à revenir les
candidats astronautes savent désormais
qu'ils ne seront pas coupés de la terre
nous vous faites a ajouté au chapitre
des soucoupes volantes inculte il va
perdre de moringhem monsieur daniel you
a été le témoin stupéfait mais
observateurs de la présence d'un de ces
engins que les scientifiques appellent
du terme de compromettant d'objets
volants non identifiés
voici la déclaration que ce nouveau
témoin a bien voulu nous faire les
derniers éléments gecimed beaux-parents
et en rentrant le soir on a percé sur la
route comme une boule rouge qui arrivait
sur nous
il arrivait sur la droite et dans un
virage de développer la route et là des
parties sur la gauche
alors on a dû freiner brusquement pour
l'éviter parce que je pouvais pas passer
en dessous tellement le passé blast et
apprennent et au suivi comme sade ou
stressant mais t'as qu'à renaître de
nous sur la gauche vous avez nettement
l'impression d'avoir été observée par
cet engin peut pas décréter au service
mais c'est bizarre qu'elle vienne où ça
passait devant notre voiture et quelle
forme avait-il en dessous c'était une
boule rouge est au dessus une masse ne
peut pas distinguer ce que c'est ce
qu'on était ébloui basse rouge
cette boue rouge se paieront cela et
c'était comme un soleil c'était en mai
au dessus on peut pas décréter on vous
donne l'impression que c'était
télécommandées ou qu'il y avait
quelqu'un qui pilotait on peut dire
qu'ils avaient quelques dents
certainement parce qu'ils y avait des
arbres et est passé entre eux dû alors
certainement qu'il voyait clair si tu
dis ou quoi
toujours est il que depuis cette
rencontre les vaches refusent leur
nourriture
les chiens sont fébriles y at il parmi
nous comme certains le prétendent des
présence invisible
[Musique]
critérium international de rivière
sportive en autriche les meilleurs
spécialistes européens ce poste un
stallone sur les hauts de la lisère en
carinthie dont les rapides très violents
de leur ménage pas les difficultés
[Musique]
comme dans toute classique du genre les
dessalage sont nombreux mais souvent
sans dommage pour les concurrents
expérimentés qui arrivent pas retrouvé
leur centre de gravité et à poursuivre
la course
un sport d'été à la hauteur des amateurs
de bateaux et de mon talent
[Musique]
le rallye des cimes s'adresse à une
catégorie voisine mais motorisés au pied
des sommets pyrénéens six jeeps dispute
autour de l'icc a trait à un tournoi en
tout terrain dont l'essentiel se déroule
sur les pistes multiair généralement
empruntée par les bergers et touristes
ou les conteneurs hadji prost mené à
près de 30 km/heure de moyenne
une belle performance si l'on considère
le terrain
[Musique]
chaque année à cette saison dans la
ville dit marie au japon se déroule une
curieuse fait qu'on appelle le matsuri
une foule masculine vêtu aux mêmes
couleurs et convenablement abreuver de
cet alcool de riz qu'on nomme le sac et
en un an deux cortèges et à contresens 2
palanquin qui portent chacun un batteurs
de tambours
à chaque carrefour les deux palanquin
s'élance l'un contre l'autre
autant de carrefour autant de batailles
il va sans dire que c'est plutôt un sens
religieux et moral
l'un des palancas représente à la fois
l'aspect mal guerrier néfastes l'autre
l'aspect femelle pacifique bienfaisant
[Applaudissements]
ces combats durent tout le jour au
coucher du soleil les palancas se
rencontrent pour un ultime combat qui se
termine dans la mer en même temps tous
les participants se précipite dans l'eau
rites purificateur qui termine la
journée on recommencera l'an prochain
[Musique]